tonight I shut out for reporters who
wouldn't take no for an answer
Christiane scheckler of the South Bend
Tribune teaming up with Ken Armstrong of
the nonprofit ProPublica pushed to get
key documents and a telling video to
expose police brutality that otherwise
would have gone unreported it was only
after this video was finally made public
that it became known what really
happened to the suspect being dragged
out of this police car and police
officials and officers in Elkhart
Indiana held to account the man's name
was Mario Guerra ledesma under arrest
for domestic battery so he was brought
into a detention area at the police
department he was placed on a chair with
his uh hence cuffed behind his back
reporter Christian Steckler of the South
Bend Tribune had already been working on
how the Elkhart Indiana Police
Department handled allegations of
misconduct when he came across this case
at one point he turned and began to spit
towards one officer that officer and
another and then jumped on top of them
and punched him in the face repeatedly
but the police at first put out a much
different version police chief and
wooden Bigler downplayed it to the
police oversight Commission and I think
they just went a little overboard when
they when they took him to the ground
without the video the chief's version a
little overboard became the official
version he made no mention of them
throwing any punches and really he just
consistently downplayed what had really
happened in the police stations
detention area Ken Armstrong is a
reporter with a non-profit group
ProPublica which has created a fund to
help support local investigative
journalism getting the video in Indiana
made all the difference
yeah he's left on the ground bleeding
afterwards for about six minutes then
he's taken out on a stretcher you know
so this was not something where two
officers simply went a little over four
it went well beyond that when the South
Bend Tribune published the video it also
identified the two other officers in the
room and the two other officers included
the mayor's son sergeant drew nice he
was the only supervisor in the room and
the other officer in the room at the
time the beating occurred was the head
of the local Fraternal Order of Police
and neither of those two officers
stopped the beating as it occurred but
they walked over as it ends and one of
them says stop and if Christian and with
your help had not pushed for the video
what do you think would have happened I
don't think anything would have happened
you know when the police chief
reprimanded the two officers in June of
2018 he concluded his letter reprimand
with a line I now consider this matter
closed
with an exclamation point but the
Tribune reporting made it impossible to
close the case right now elkhart leaders
are dealing with the department in
disarray tonight police chief edwin
Bigler suspended without pay top police
officials blamed the newspaper for all
its problems how cars assistant police
chief todd Thayer made an impassioned
speech about his anger over the reports
in the Tribunal everything why are they
coming over here into our backyard and
trying to disrupt everything that we
built since then the chief was forced to
resign the mayor has announced he will
not run for re-election and the two
officers who actually threw the punches
seen in the video they have been charged
with misdemeanor battery and are
awaiting trial
they have pleaded not guilty it's the
kind of local reporting that is so
critical and it's the kind of local
reporting that's suffering given the
landscape and journalists in these days
you know so it's one of the things that
public I was hoping to address with the
local reporting network in some small
way make up for that and and to help
bolster this kind of critical reporting
and in local news rooms so a shout out
to those two reporters Kristen Sheckler
and Kent Armstrong
and their organizations the South Den
Tribune and ProPublica for refusing to
accept the official version of events a
reminder for all that journalism is not
meant to be stenography and the good
news is that Pro Publica
is now funding some 14 other local
investigative journalists around the
country that's our program for this week
thanks for joining us we'll see you here
again next week